you have the right to remain silent
[Music]
let's do this Karim needs to go by Franz
house after school
and he asked that you pick him up when
my mom dated this one guy we became BFFs
you're BFFs with a grown-ass man there's
literally documentaries on Netflix about
why that's so sick and [ __ ] up I think
that's a difference you expect us to be
pious [ __ ] out of my face man good talk
I knew when I told you about that white
couple is humping my mom well now you
see what happens when you [ __ ] with me
wrong don't you
dick is rubbing against my was it turned
towards me I don't want to make things
even is everything okay
this all started when your son tried to
have me killed because he saw us having
sex this morning now the most dangerous
drug dealers in Detroit are trying to
kill us so what in the day a white guy
my friend Sharon was right oh [ __ ]
[Music]
why are you [ __ ] ringing a doorbell
just don't touch [ __ ] no fingerprints
thank you right here
tell your mom we went to Chuck E Cheese
to be honest woman skier that [ __ ] added
me I mean where do you even start excuse
me my friend here would like to practice
talking with a lady tell me about
yourself I was born and raised in
Detroit and have an associate's degree
in biology and I'm studying to be a
veterinarian
[Music]
[Music]